hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
in chapter 18 of his work leviathan
thomas hobbes goes on to talk about the
rights
of the sovereign and really these rights
are
specified in relation to the subjects of
the sovereign it's what the sovereign
gets to do or can't be held accountable
for
in relation to the subjects and you
could say well this you know this sounds
pretty bad why would the subjects
want to have such an absolute authority
established over them
for hobbs it's so that they can have a
reliable
you know and safe way of living he
actually
mentions towards the end of it that you
know
some people might say that there's a lot
of inconveniences here but
they don't consider that the estate of
man can never be without some
in commodity or other and that the
greatest
that in any form of government can can
possibly happen to the people in general
is scarce sensible
in respect of the miseries and horrible
calamities that accompany a
civil war or that dissolute condition of
a masterless men without subjection
to laws and a coercive power to tie
their hands from rapine
and revenge and so you know he's saying
listen
it would be way worse if you didn't have
this sovereign authority there
the other thing i want to point out as
well that comes after his listing
of the many different rights is that he
says these
are the rights which make the essence of
sovereignty so
these compose what it means to be
sovereign and he says these are
incommunicable
and inseparable this is really quite
important
the sovereign cannot give up these these
rights to
somebody else and they remain
inseparable from each other so he gives
for example uh and this is coming from
you know the background of the english
civil war
that the sovereign is the only one who
can actually have
military forces you don't want other
people having militias
but if you remove the sovereign's
ability to
lay to you know raise funds through
taxes
that means that they can't actually
support the military so they can't enact
that right and so all of these rights
sort of reinforce each other
hobbes is saying it's a package deal you
you get all of these
and if you try to take away any of them
you're undermining the sovereign and
putting everybody at risk for going back
into
civil war so what are these
rights the first one is that he says
once you've actually bound yourself by a
covenant
and you've entered into a commonwealth
you
own the actions and judgments of of the
sovereign you cannot lawfully make a new
covenant
amongst yourselves to be obedient to any
other
in anything whatsoever without his
permission now this would extend to like
you know
maybe even having clubs and having
officers at the clubs that would have to
be
ratified in some way by the supreme
authority maybe they don't care so much
about that
what they're what hobbs is really
concerned about is having
private allegiances or forming compacts
or
or factions within the society says you
can't do that
the sovereign has a right to your
absolute loyalty
in that respect if they want to allow
you to
you know create new assemblies so you
could do charitable organization work or
something like that the sovereign can
decide that but you have to get
permission
first the other one that follows from
this
and it's kind of similar to the fourth
one is the second one
he says that um here we go
because the right of bearing the person
of them all is given to him they make
sovereign by covenant
only of one to another and not of him to
any of them
there can happen no breach of covenant
on the part of the sovereign
consequently none of his subjects by any
pretense of forfeiture
can be freed from his suggest from his
uh subjection
so the the sovereign
is not subject you can say to the social
contract
they're above it they're the one who
enforces it
and so they can't be held to be bound by
it or
presumably the laws of nature besides
like say the third law which we're going
to talk about in
in the fourth uh right
here so that's you know covering a lot
the third has to do with when we
enter into the agreement in the first
place but this could be extended
tacitly or implicitly to all of those
who are born
into or don't take part in the formation
of a commonwealth hobbes says that
when when a sovereign has been chosen by
the majority
of the people who are choosing it
everybody else is stuck with that
they have to enter into the arrangement
they don't get to say
things like no i didn't vote for them so
i'm not going to be bound by them
hobbes would say if you do that you're
essentially
getting ready for civil war you're
essentially saying that you're not going
to cooperate and so then
you could be punished for that
if you voluntarily entered into the
congregation of them that were assembled
you have to stand to what the major part
should ordain
the fourth one sort of like the second
one but making it a little bit more
explicit he says
because every subject is by this
institution author of all the actions
and judgments of the sovereign
it follows whatsoever he does that is
the sovereign
it can be no injury to any of his
subjects nor ought he to be
by any of them accused of justice so
injustice rather so the sovereign
literally cannot
do wrong in a moral or political
sense whatever they do is
okay even if it's stupid even if they uh
made you know informative they they had
inadequate information and they made a
decision
based on that even if they're being
motivated by their own
personal animosity or preference as an
individual
it's the sovereign so you're you're
stuck with it
um along with this goes another
key thing hobbes uh you know in the
civil war he saw the sovereign actually
punished
he says no person that has sovereign
power can justly be put to death
or otherwise in any manner by his
subjects be
punished so the sovereign
is above the law not only in terms of
you know
justice and injustice but also in terms
of punishments
with the sixth we get to something that
is really
quite interesting and deepens the power
of the sovereign
and also might be raising some red flags
for quite a few people he says
it's a next to the sovereignty to be
judge of what opinions and doctrines
are averse and what conducing to peace
and consequently on what occasions how
far and what men are
to be trusted with all in speaking to
multitudes of people and who shall
examine
the doctrines of all books before they
be published
so what we've got here is deciding which
doctrines
can actually be communicated in public
forums
and who is entitled to present them
or to argue for them or to teach them
and what books can be published what can
be published
in books why why is this so important
why couldn't hobbes just say
listen so long as you obey the law say
whatever you want you can like say that
the law
sucks or anything you like but you have
to obey
why is it so important that there be
this
scope of censorship and
oversight he says that the actions of
men proceed from their opinions and
in the well-governing opinions consists
the well-governing of men's actions in
order to their peace and
concord and so you know he says that
teacher you know uh teachers you can
have false doctrines
contrary truths and what happens is
people disagree with each other and this
brings us back into a state of war
as a matter of fact he says the most
sudden and
rough bustling in of a new truth that
can be never does break the peace
but only sometimes awake the war men
that are so remissly governed that they
dare take up arms to defend or introduce
an opinion
are still in war if you're willing to
use violence
to get your point across you're actually
still in a state of war
and the sovereign should take care of
that
number seven he says that the sovereign
should get to decide
the whole power of prescribing the rules
whereby every person may know what goods
they may enjoy
what actions they may do without being
molested by any of his fellow subjects
this is what men call propriety
so you get to decide what is mine and
what
is yours right and he says
of the good evil lawful and unlawful and
the actions of subjects so
this is quite important right
people are going to disagree about about
whether
something is right or wrong or whether
somebody's damaged somebody else's
property
or things like that so there's going to
be controversies
the sovereign according to hobbes gets
to be the only judge he has the right of
judicature that is to say of hearing and
deciding all controversies
which may arise concerning law or
concerning
fact and he says without the decision of
controversies
there's no protection of one subject
against the injuries
of another the laws concerning mayhem
what is mine
and to him are all in vain and we would
be back in the state of
war so the sovereign judges those things
and they are the
you know ultimate court um number nine
the sovereign gets to conduct foreign
policy
hobbes frames this primarily in who
you're at war with or at peace with
we can probably imagine that this would
also extend to say economic policy
or things like that so you know you
don't get to decide
for yourself how
you know how you're going to have an
attitude if you're the english
towards the french or anything like that
right
uh 10th this is very important this is
how the sovereign's power
gets extended and trickles down to
everybody in society
the sovereign gets to choose and notice
the four classes of people that hobbes
talks about
counselors those who are going to give
information or advice
the sovereign ministers those who are in
charge
of you know areas like say the treasury
or war
or development of the interior
magistrates
those who are going to be charged with
with you know keeping
the peace in general and officers a very
vast uh segment of society that could
include
everybody from you know dog catcher all
the way up to the
the person who minced the coins or
whatever it's going to be
so the sovereign chooses these and these
are agents
of the sovereign they get to take on the
sovereign doesn't lose any power
by delegating power to them but the
sovereign is thereby
able to you know have many hands many
eyes many ears
throughout society the 11th
sovereign uh he says has committed the
power of rewarding with riches or honor
and of punishing with corporal or
pecuniary punishment or
ignominy which is you know bad uh repute
every subject according to the law he
have formally made
or if there be no law made according as
he shall judge most
it's most conducive to the encouraging
of men to serve the commonwealth
or deterring from doing disservice to
the same so
the rewards and punishments get doled
out by the sovereign and notice that
these are not just money these are not
just
you know corporal punishment it could be
honor or dishonor
it's up to the sovereignty to choose
that and then lastly he says we also
have to straighten some things out with
the laws of honor
what are going to be the ways in which
people are designated how do we rank
people what signs do other people
have to give this is up to the sovereign
and
nobody else they get to as he says
establish the laws of honor and a public
rate of the worth of such men as
have deserved or able to deserve well of
the commonwealth and notice the name he
says
and that there be force in the hands of
some or others to put these laws
into execution so it's not just saying
you know
we should aspire to treat people in this
way and honor them in this way
there's laws that enforce this
so all of these are rolled into what it
means for hobbes to be
a sovereign to be an absolute ruler
and hobbes thinks that if you want a
state of peace
rather than a state of war where you're
sooner or later going to lose everything
and
you know or you might come out on top
for a while and
you know be unhappy because somebody
bigger and badder comes along if you
want
that you have to have all of these given
to the authority figure that you
establish
as the sovereign
you